hello everyone and welcome to the last
game of the st. Louis rapid and blitz
tournament this is a game from the Blitz
section the second day of the blitz
level Harlan versus Maxine Maxine
Marshall I grab the two of them have
been going at it from the beginning to
the end of the tournament 11 to the lead
in the tournament then maxime overtook
him then I want to delete again and now
it is definitely a game that could
decide well that that will decide the
standings so without further ado we're
gonna have two short announcements one
is regarding the thumbnails a lot of you
have been saying that you don't like the
photo of the winner in the thumbnail now
the reason I don't use two people in the
thumbnail is because well I very rarely
have two good photos of of players for
the thumbnail and you don't use bad for
us for the thumbnail that's just not how
YouTube works you have to have good
thumbnails so I have devised a way for
well for most of the times how I will be
able to use the photo only one form in
the thumbnail without you actually
knowing who the winner is so this is the
the coin I have it's five Croatian kunas
there you have it I don't know if you
can see it it's the brown bear the
arctos and I will just flip it before
the signing and the thumbnail if it's a
bear I'm gonna use the player with the
white pieces if it's the amount I will
use the player with the black pieces you
will not be able to verify have I
actually done this but I'm telling you I
will be doing this you know so feel free
to tell everyone your friends and family
you know in in the library and the bar
that this is how I am choosing my
thumbnails from now on there will be
exception to this rule for example if I
don't have the photo of the other player
of the or if the photo is really bad or
but but I will mention at the end of the
video if I used a different photo than
what the coin said so and also it will
well it will ease my problems of when
choosing the thumbnail so I'm just gonna
flip it and whatever the coin says
that's that who gets the thumbnail also
another short announcement I just wanted
to make a lot of you have been asking me
from time to time well for the past two
years if I have a like a a postal mail
or if you can send me something
physically like an old newspapers
article if you have an old article
regarding Fisher or a couple Blanc or
something like that your you can copy it
and then just send it to me I would be
more than happy to receive such mail and
you know if a lot of you have such
articles maybe we can build like a huge
library of old chess articles and
whenever some of you send me something I
will share it with everyone and then we
can increase our knowledge together so
in the description below I will as of
this video forward put my well postal
mail however you call it and then you
can send me such articles if you have
them so that those were the two
announcements now let's get back to the
game so it's eleven Arnim versus Maxie
Marshall a graph the final game of the
tournament eleven opens with d4 with
Knight to f6 Knight to f3 sorry about
that and not be six already
maxime prepare stuff in keto the light
square bishop it's sort of an some sort
of an Indian Indian game with g3 11 does
the same he wants to be in care of his
light square Bishop to b7 Bishop to g2
and now c5 we have C 4 C capture son d4
by Maxine with castles by Levin waiting
to recapture and now II 6 we have b3
preparing the ship to be too tough in
Cairo Deirdre Bishop as well and now
push up the c5 defending the d4 pawn but
there's no real way to defend it as 11
can easily attack it three times so
Bishop to b2 and castles and here there
is one game in the database where white
played Knights to a three but here 11
just goes for the pawn right away with
Bishop captures on d4 and now Knight to
a6 preparing to meet Bishop captures
wooden Knight captures on c5 so lemon
just develops with Knight to c3
Queen to e7 now gaining another defender
to the bishop here also connecting
routes the veldt in developing the Queen
and now Knights the a1 forcing a trade
of light squared bishop swell bishop
character s and g2 what
well what instead of capturing you could
also play d5 here but Maxime decides
that he would rather
trade bishops with Bishop captures
Knight captures and now comes Brooke f38
and here the problem with not playing d5
is that 11 could have played efore now
preventing d5 but 11 doesn't think it
necessary and if Levin had play d4 here
we would not have a game so interesting
as the one that we're gonna see 11
played rook the c1 here and now we have
rook a to c8 we have night the b5 going
after the a7 pawn and now d5 the Queen
now the defense the a7 point and also
you get rid of your backwards d7 pawn
and here 11 says okay now your knight is
defending the d5 pawn so I'm just gonna
capture it but also by capturing Bishop
captures on f6 I'm forcing you to play
Queen captures on f6 if you don't want
to mess up your pawn structure in front
of the King and also while the Queen
captures you will no longer be defending
your a summon point so this is what
Maxime does with Queen captures on f6
and 11 goes for the pawn with Knight
captures on a7 and now you could harass
the night for example route to c7 is a
deadly move you're threatening the
Knights to move away and if Knight goes
here then you play pawn captures here
you open up a discovered attack towards
the Queen and then well whatever
why does you were gonna capture on b3
and so on and so on so after Knight
captures on a7 Maxime says okay I don't
even have to waste a move we drove to c7
I'm just gonna play D captures and c4
right away so what do you do here your
queen is under attack and well you could
move the Queen you could play Queen to
c2 and then we're gonna get the same
align with rook to c7 but this is why it
was better to play rook to c7 right away
maybe it's hard to say but it's
somebody's game it's even irrelevant but
it allows them 11 to go for Knight
captures on C a so he sacrifices the
Queen basically gives up the Queen for
two rooks we have Luke out for some d1
rook seek out for some d1 and now C 3 so
it's usually really awesome to have two
rooks for the Queen but with black
having the passport already on c3 it's
gonna make things a bit harder for white
so we have Knight to d6 white wants to
get the knight back into the game as
soon as possible if the Queen somehow
gets
to defend the d6 square you will not be
able to bring the knight back into the
game
but there was a stronger move here
although I have to repeat it's a blitz
game a3 is a move you will not find in a
blitz game when the clock is ticking
preventing the knife from jumping to be
for to support the push of the Ponte c2
but also if Bishop captures that then
just rook to a one wins the wins apiece
you either lose the bishop or remove the
bishop and lose them denied if you try
something like Queen to d8 to give up
the bishop so after Queen captures here
you defend the night then just nice the
a7 and if Queen tries to defend now
let's say Queen b6 you guard the Bishop
Knight b5 attacks the Queen and the
bishop next move you just win a piece so
a3 I just you know decided to show it
even though in a blitz game it's really
an impossible move to find with Knight
to d6
and now h5 by Maxine he starts an attack
against the White King although again c2
is just deadly here you either force the
move away from the defense of the night
or if the rook stays there let's see you
try Knight d4 with an attack on the
Queen this would come with Czech Queen
to be - and now rook the c1 getting the
rock out of the way Bishop to e3 and you
cannot prevent Queen captures on c1 also
a very interesting tactic whatever you
do let's say 93 you go after the c2 pawn
Knight before you just defended next
move you're gonna capture and there's
nothing wife can do whatever you play
captures in c1 you can capture here
captures and now the thread is just
captures and promote to a queen
so here White has to give up a piece and
now black is winning just a very nice
idea see - instead of h5 but okay with
h5 and now Knight to e4 right away not
allowing this plan Levin spotted it with
Queen to e5 Knight captures Knight
captures and night to e3 guarding the c2
square with b5 now preparing to put b4
to have a nice protective passed pawn
and c3 and 11 of course does not allow
this with b4 and now Knight to e4 just a
very dangerous piece to have on e4 with
rope to d3 and now comes h4 hoping for
hoping for h3 to get the
some meeting ideas you know going we
have G captures on h4 11 of course
doesn't allow it and now Queen to f6
going after the pawn with f3 kicking the
night back and now nice - D - attacking
the rook on f1 and here 11 plate rook
the c1 the correct move was rook to d1
but again in the Blitz game it's hard to
see why rook to d1 was the better move
but first let's see what happens after
rook to see one after Luke the c1 maxime
found brilliant move that wins him the
game so feel free to pause the video and
try to find this idea while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent finder of ideas
that win games and for those who just
want to enjoy the show
Knight captures on f3 check the point is
if the knight is captured just boom g6
check picks up the rook that's why I
said rook to d1 was better instead of
rook to c1 because if the rook was in d1
you will not be able to capture the rook
here so that's one of the things that
could have improved lemons position but
okay after Knight captures an f3 of
course Levin did not recapture he played
King to h1 and okay Knight back to d4 at
least you got rid of one very important
point and now you've opened up this
diagonal so black can use it for attack
we have roped f1 by Levin attacking the
Queen Queen captures on h4 and now rook
captures and c3 as possible you should
get rid of this pawn but doesn't you
know get you out of the out of trouble
due to Queenie fourth check and now nice
to g2 let's say you block and now Queen
captures any two still black will grab a
lot of points here so after Queen
captures an h4 with a knight capture
Sunday night night g2 attacking the
Queen Queen to e4 and only now rook a
person c3 so basically going into the
same line but it wasn't necessary to go
into the same line Queen captures an e2
and now rook the CH check we have Quinta
h7 and now rook see the c1 bringing the
rook back as the rook on f1 was under
attack
and now f6 so still white still has two
rooks for the Queen but it's very hard
to do anything against the black king
we have rook ct1 sorry that's a pawn
rook c 2 e 1 and now Queen captures on a
2 grabbing yet another pawn we've looked
at e3 and now II five so black really
improving the position there's nothing
you can do against this pawn chain with
the rook the knight is nicely placed on
d4 we've looped h3 track kinked g8 and
now Knight back to e3 and now because
the F pawn is no longer here you have
Queen to a eight check with King to g1
and now Knight to e2 check came to f2
and not nice to F for attacking the rook
so you have to move it
rook to f3 is played but now comes Queen
to a - check
notice how the night is nicely covering
these these squares if you play King you
want then Queen to e 2 will be checkmate
so King to g1 and now Queen to d2 just
going after the pawn so whatever you
play you attack the Queen with the rook
you're just gonna lose that pawn and
there's no better way to do it
you could play rook the b1 but it's only
temporary Queen d4 and still it's gonna
be very hard for white so 11 tried rook
to d1 but Queen before as we said Knight
to f5 now and queen T for just going
after the rook knife to h4 defending and
here Knights the e to check opening up
an attack against White's knight King to
have 2 hoping to trade night for night
and then play 2 rooks against the Queen
but we have Knights to d4 and it was in
this position that level Aragon resigned
the game as he will eat or lose material
here the knight is under attack the rook
is under attack and you don't really
have a good reply here you could try
something like rook to h3 this does get
the rook away from there and at defense
tonight but then just queenie to check
picks up the rook on d1 so after 94
sorry Levin did not resign he ran out of
time on the clock and that's the reason
why he lost but he can resign here
without a problem
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it and well let's just check out the
standings of the st. Louis rapid and
blitz tournament if you don't want to
see them you know I pause the video or
close your eyes but here they are the
standings after three days of rapid and
two days of blitz the
of the same who's rappin in blitz
tournament is 11 Aragon in fact even
though he lost the final game to Maxine
with 22 points but only later I found
out that ding leader and Maxine Varsha
holograph and young AE all three of them
won their games in the last round and
level lost so no one had even a chance
to catch up to 11 but I don't think the
Levin knew that as lavon's a second in
front him that he won the tournament
after the last round so I don't think he
was all that much you know obsessed with
the result but there we have it with 22
points 11 Oregon followed by three
people tied for second we have ding
Liron Maxime holograph in you young ye
excellent result for the Chinese players
as well as the maxi Marshall de Graaf
the Frenchman 19 and a half Sergey
Karjakin magnus carlsen with 17 that's a
pretty bad placement for a world
champion but you know you can't win them
all 16 and a half
Richard report Fabiano Khurana with 15
linear dominguez Paris with 13 and a
half and Rahim Amira with 12 a lot we
have been asking what's wrong with the
Magnus its it doesn't seem to be
anything wrong you just can't play every
tournament that well but also it could
have something to do with him opening up
the the Chess Club where he paid 1000
people to join for free I think it cost
him like $60,000 or something like that
to open up the club and well it was I
think I'm not really all that familiar
with the story but it has something to
do with wood gambling and maybe that's
something that's on his mind now and he
doesn't feel all that although a great
about doing it it could be the reason
but it could be that it has nothing to
do with that so I'm just you know
putting it out there maybe some of you
know some more so if you do you know
feel free to share we're gonna comment
on that as well and also I would just
like to show this it is the photo of the
knot death and not that sorry about that
there it is
these are the the Blitz ratings after
this tournament so as you can see now
Hikaru Nakamura is the current highest
rated blitz player in the world after
course and now lost 64 points due to due
to playing poorly in this tournament and
you can as you can see in number 20 is
maxime beaugeois graph
after Paris and st. Louis lost a hundred
and eighty-five Blitz rating points
which is just insane
he was the highest rated player in the
world with a reigning over twenty nine
thousand twenty-nine hundred and now he
is 20th after he lost a hundred and
eighty five points which is just insane
I would date blitz you know ratings come
and go so it's gonna be like that for
quite some time now until you know
everything is nicely leveled but yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Amy Hernandez of
Midland with Lisa st. Louis James
toucher and golf software comm for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon
well we'll finish this tournament but
checking up on your suggestions and of
course continuing and finishing up the
capablanca saga thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day